Are your walls doing enough for you?
Are they smart enough?
Do they spend way too much time
just holding up the ceiling and
dividing your home into rooms?
Shouldn’t they also be listening to you
and anticipating your every need?
Researchers have found a way to
make the most responsive walls yet.
Imagine, for example, as you sit down on the sofa
the TV turns on, lights dim
when you start watching something on your laptop,
or Alexa lets you know that your kids have
turned on a portable video game system
somewhere in the house.
This isn’t very difficult to do:
The first step is converting a wall into a giant antenna.
In this study, researchers used tape
to make a grid on the wall,
then covered over it with water-based paint
containing nickel.
They removed the tape,
which left behind a pattern of metallic diamonds
that act as electrodes.
They then connected the electrodes to a computer
and painted the wall with standard latex paint,
hiding any sign of its new capabilities.
Now the wall can watch your every move.
Touching or moving an arm or limb close to the wall
changes the wall’s electrostatic fields,
just as a finger touching an iPad does.
It can tell if you are exercising
or heading for the kitchen
and if connected to your house computer,
may one day turn on energizing exercise music
or flip the kitchen lights on.
The newly alert wall, can even sense
what you are interacting with in the room:
lamps, laptops, TVs
and other electronic devices all generate
distinctive electromagnetic fields.
Eventually such walls
—which the team created for $20/square meter--
could feed this information to
electronic personal assistants
or your phone when you're not home
-- hopefully not the government